la france elle s'apprête à quitter le
mali après neuf ans de présence dans le
pays 59 soldats français sont morts en
opération au sahel dont 52 au mali les
soldats français s'apprête à quitter le
pays dans un délai de quatre à six mois
ils vont sort déployés notamment au
niger un départ sous pression pour
l'armée française depuis la prise de
pouvoir par la junte malienne depuis
neuf ans les jihadistes ont étendu leur
zone d'influencé
comment réagit la population malienne la
correspondance à bamako dan fleurs
lespiau depuis les annonces de macron la
vie ici suit son cours ces annonces
n'ont pas créé des mois particulier
c'est ce sont des annonces qui n'était
une surprise pour personne en fait la
majorité des maliens le voit dans les
box tops se félicite du retrait de la
france au profit de nouveaux
partenariats créés récemment par exemple
avec la russie mais ce sont c'est une
opinion qui ne fait pas l'unanimité au
sein par exemple de la classe politique
d'opposition
le retrait de barques n inquiète à
l'heure où le mali est placée sous
sanctions de la cedeao depuis le 9
janvier et traverse en plus de la crise
d'insécurité à une crise économique
et puis une crise politique avec des
autorités de transition qui ont entamé
un bras de fer avec la communauté
économique des états d'afrique de
l'ouest et la communauté
internationale reste à savoir
aujourd'hui qu'elle sera
finalement la suite et surtout l'après
barkan